are you there hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to layers of
fear by this close on its own I didn't
do that but now we got another adventure
to be had in this house of haunted
[ __ ]
oh never mind it's gonna be happy and
cheerful
lovely thanks daughter mine don't mind
your raging alcoholic dad delirious is
that from the raging alcoholism selfish
another step in the healing process of
alcoholism drunk I kind of called this
one I don't know why but I okay yeah
whatever slamming doors jana Rama oh
wait oh no oh they're still there
they're still there
there's dude oh okay alright
it got fed up with me being far too
intelligent for it
gnome her Oh ignored no yes no there's
gonna be an actual person here how am I
supposed to ignore her oh I don't want
to ignore her
Oh what what the hell he's doing here
what is going on hello okay bye then I'm
gonna - okay all right cool
great oh joy why Oh doc cut the crap
tell me how bad it is coming to grill no
it can't be her she looks like a corpse
is that him after seeing his wife after
the burns happened zap do the thing I'm
just gonna close that door and ignore
her whoa is that symbolism I said
something I'm supposed to understand no
no okay okay oh god oh god oh I'm gonna
be back here now Oh God
what happened
it sounded like my intestines came
exploding out through my bones and last
time that happened I didn't survive
death is but a layer layers of fear I
didn't know that I didn't know I wasn't
supposed to go into the pitch blackness
I didn't know I wasn't supposed to
approach the horrible shadow lady I mean
my lovely wife oh this is a fun time
we're having a good time here oh how can
two people who once loved each other so
fully so profoundly drift soap are far
apart my husband barely speaks to me
anymore
he's just slithers in and out of his
study obsessively working on one failed
painting after another
he won't even sleep with me anymore I
can tell he's disgusted by me look he
gave me the other day that pathetic
hurtful look a combination of shame
guilt and repulsion I have come to
realize that I become monsters
Oh God Oh Oh am i dead am i dead Oh am i
dead oh my dad oh oh oh oh oh oh it
feels like nothing a woman should ever
experience still being the good wife
that I am I decided to realize my
husband's fantasy if he thinks me a
monster I will sure as hell fart
oh I'm not turning around no way Jose no
way hello honey Oh No thank you
Oh God oh damn oh holy crap Oh balls
squeak squeak squeaky squeak squeaky
squeaks
Rooney oh alright okay okay
I'm okay are you okay I'm okay
hey what's out over there
what's making all that no good good
looking out for me bro oh stop look at
me like that it's just a little
something to help me focus on my work
that's all
sure and what about the hundreds and
hundreds of bottles you got my back
right bro you got my back you you won't
criticize my horrible horrible drinking
habits will you oh oh god oh no oh [ __ ]
me god damn it
ah thank you soothing piano music you
sure are in time could this a could you
help a dude out and clear all this poop
out of my pants it's suddenly appeared
for no reason
honey your carpentry work is delightful
Oh criminy Christmas do I have a choice
to make here alright fine
let's see what you got hang on maybe
there's something in the dresser over
here my love can you hear me no as a
matter of fact no I cannot and I never
will and please shut up even though I
can't hear you okay whoops he's on about
the damn rats again I don't think I've
even seen one but that doesn't stop him
from laying out traps all over the place
he claims he can hear them in the walls
and there must be hundreds of them god I
[ __ ] hope it's true
I hope they crawl out at night and eat
you and your sleep you cruel
self-obsessed pathetic drunk okay
alright fine you know what I'm going I'm
facing my fears I'm gonna peel away
another layer make another bad dog no no
I'm not bye Joe God oh okay let's let's
dance baby I can look past the burns oh
god I don't wanna here we go
cool well that happened again something
tells me I shouldn't go running into the
arms of my wife but I mean don't I want
to so now we're loving loving husband
should to do all God why why am I making
the choice to go down these paths is the
game changing and diverging on me sorry
I think I just did a dance there oh okay
okay so there's a white piece missing
where's the white piece actually there's
two white pieces missing aha there's one
got that one
what am what'd I miss
reconnect with your partner rebuild your
relationship rediscover the joy of
marriage rekindle the flame don't worry
you're not alone perfect relationships
may look great on the silver screen but
the rest of us mortals have to face a
simple truth nobody's perfect and you
know what that's fine
in fact many loving couple struggled of
a day-to-day life in a relationship this
does not make them any less special it
just takes some work and we're Dell our
consultant all trained experts in the
field with hubby identify George W
Devin's rendered over didn't do it never
too late it might be too late I think my
loving wife has killed me in the face
like twice now I mean I fixed the
checkered board is that is that pretty
close to fixing my marriage maybe was
that a mini game that's gonna unlock a
super secret down the road talking
behind their backs oh god oh god I saw
that ice what what you [ __ ] you jeez you
dick what are you doing huh you want go
bra I just had my ribs eaten by my wife
yeah that's euphemism take that for what
you will I'll take it for the fact that
I'm dead hello who are you the following
list is a compilation of the most common
systems this is schizophrenia okay so
let's see blank expression stares in the
space yes involuntary facial movements
yes
insomnia have noticed unusual gestures
postures always had that unable to
experience joy from activities
definitely person depersonalization was
that even mean mock were clumsy movement
might be from the accident front anger
resentment more passive-aggressive lack
of motivation yes suicidal tendencies
good move good mood bruh good mood bruh
good mood
can I go home yet I found that liquor
isn't that what I was looking for
isn't that my new painting tool probably
honey I need I need a nap I need a nap
after this one this is been a stressful
episode oh man
wait this is the same room wait a minute
oh no it's exactly the same okay
god damn wolves on your face oh okay
it's a baby oh it's a [ __ ] a baby head
nuclear explosion my stop no none of
that no no no no no no no thank you
thank you no I ain't having none of that
having none of that okay Barney Oh
Oh
hey buddy you got my back bro oh sorry
the door's locked
don't kill me
okay bye okay time for happy and fun I
don't know whom my daughter's drawn
there with the tall slender man figure
he's like some twiddly tall thin slender
guy weird well it got nice when's it
gonna get bad oh oh so nice oh look at
this oh look at all this
oh that's locked why's it locked there a
key or something
hello hi hello here we go okay oh it's
getting bad
quick before gets bad happy memories
nothing Bad's gonna happen to me
Oh daughter still alive my wife didn't
get burned Oh everything was great
I'm a great artist oh oh no oh no oh no
oh oh
choo choo here comes the happy train hey
hey ho ho what you gonna do oh so fun
fires all day long oh god what is that
everybody joining in the musical
everyone clap at home a million people
across a nation oh oh oh
enough
yeah
bye okay bye now
hey happy happy happy happy happy today
[ __ ] that was a weird drug trip I didn't
want any part of oh man this games too
good it's a special brush like a horse
hair brush but different at that point I
hesitated will this really work
[ __ ] it I was already halfway through
and besides it's not like I can just put
it all back and forget the whole thing
is that a brush made out of your
daughter's hair Oh mommy mommy died oh
good oh good god damn oh that was
nothing huh I need I need a break please
let me have a break thank you thank you
Oh God
Oh can I have a break please I just want
to rest I wanna rest my weary head oh
that's not good hey that's on the game
art oh good
yay why is there blood on the plate Oh
cause I'm painting with blood okay I got
it okay so that might be the last of it
I think that I think that might be the
last of it but I'm gonna end this
episode here if there's any more all I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna add it on after I
say goodbye now but I'm gonna see if
there's more I don't know if there is
but thank you everybody so much for
watching hope you all recover from the
explosion of peeing your pants and
horrible heart attacks that everyone has
received so thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video
Oh No